and i i i'm so blown away by the
impressions and how fast you're able to
get
th the la um i don't think was the last
thing i saw you do uh kim kardashian
talking to pete davidson oh yeah
facetime facetiming pete davidson that's
on is that here is that on instagram
i think that's on both oh there it is
there you are you're both characters if
you see it if you go to instagram you'll
see it his face kind of looks like each
you know who it is but it's the
impressions and the looks that are so
funny listen to this this is kim kardash
i can't hear it
let's start it again oh hey let's start
again
hello
hey babe it's me kim k
oh hi
let's watch a movie at the same time
while we're face-taining okay
i want to see the matrax the outfits
look super cute oh major's cool yeah i
haven't seen that new one yet
what are the old ones about so i don't
get
lost uh
it's about this guy who's like the one
or whatever
the one what
uh the one who does slow motion cry the
best i guess
[Laughter]
wait let me go back
in the future robots use people as
batteries but the people don't know it
because they're in the matrix
what is the matrix
ah
it's like a video game but the graphics
are sick
oh
yeah so then this black guy offers neo a
blue pill or a red pill and the red pill
wakes him up and the blue pill he stays
asleep in the matrix
so dayquil or nyqual
so if you take nyquil you become a
battery
well the blue pill
yeah yeah you stay a battery
why does he need to take a pill to stay
what he already is
what
the black guy only needs to offer him a
red pal the blue pill is stupid
uh
oh wait i know why cause he takes the
blue pill he forgets she ever met that
black guy
we
wait can i get that pill
that's brilliant
you are so good really let me ask you
something have you not have you ever
auditioned for lauren michaels for
saturday night live i had such a
disaster audition years ago did you tape
it
no
they might i know they taped the thing
but i was um
uh you're so perfect for that show
you're better than anybody on that show
now i agree no you really are but the
writing and the timing all of it is just
really cool thank you you really are i
you gotta somebody's got a there's gotta
be a campaign if you're listening you
gotta forward all these instagram and
youtube things to lauren michaels so
what i went down there and uh i i just
sent in a tape and i wasn't expecting
whatever then they uh flew me out to new
york and it was it just felt so big and
i was just so scared i was in a hotel
room for two days like practicing you
get like six minutes
and you know you're in that mindset like
do it correctly
you know that mindset when you're
nervous maybe you don't get that no i
get really nervous but my my nerves
aren't
do it correctly my my nerves are about
like i'm gonna forget yeah i'm going to
go blank it's not going to come out
you know it's not about i'm not good on
preparation yeah so who correctly is not
your best friend no it's not at all so i
get there there's 30 of us
and uh it's like john mulaney was
auditioning in new crawl it was a good
group of people and i i knew some of
them and uh
i
i was there's there's 30 of us i go just
please not first i'm saying in my head
because she's going to decide what the
order is
and i always gotten like first and i
just want to like get relaxed and i was
too nervous and she's like first is kyle
done again
i was like and then i start going you
can do this kyle like it's first is good
you know
start lying to myself i'm not but i also
hear that when you go up
you're not
like doing well in a club is different
than doing well in front of them because
everybody who's ever made it has told me
that the deadness in that room is
terrifying even you have no idea that
you did it well so you're first yeah you
get called in well i'm in my i'm in the
little dressing room the producer comes
in and i'm i'm at a level of terror that
i've never felt before of nerves you
know
and i think part of it was a just like a
dream job and part of it was i wasn't
totally prepared
and um
so then they start miking me up that
makes you really nervous when they're
miking you
you know because i usually audition you
like go in whatever it's a room but like
it just feels like you're about to
perform on a tv show or something and
then the guy who's like the camera guy
goes i'm gonna count you in three two
one you go right in your stuff go right
in your stuff that's really stuck in my
head you know okay three two one three
two one go written with my stuff that's
terrifying like there's a bear about to
attack me the level of terror i have so
i walk out there and uh
is it is this at the studio or yeah well
this is at conan because the olympics
usually it's at this the the snl studio
but they were they were using that for
the olympics for something so it was at
conor o'brien's studio
so which is already kind of intimidating
when you go to new york and you're in 30
rock which is the epicenter of
everything show business it's like so
you're on the fifth or eighth floor
wherever that is i had done conan and uh
i remember being back you get like kind
of crunch behind the curtain before you
go out just like what am i i don't want
to do this i'm terri it's like just like
you're feels like you're going out to
the gallows like you're about to go get
right your head cut off it's like the
feeling
um
so which i'm sure not everyone has
that's that's the feeling i have i would
imagine anybody who's auditioned for
there has that same feel yeah so i walk
out there i got that guy's thought in my
head like three two one going to your
stuff so i'm just staring at the camera
just straight ahead and they're over to
the left all sitting there and how many
people probably like nine it's like seth
meyers and laura michaels so i just walk
out i'm staring at the camera
and nothing's happening
and it's like dead silent and then
lauren michaels goes
hello
like hello if they had one so oh hey hi
hello
i turned back to the camera
dead silence for a long time right it's
not counting them in and then that kind
of silence isn't golden
whatever the opposite of gold is so then
lauren goes are you okay
i haven't even started my audition and
it's over
where am i like are you okay like what's
wrong with you and i just
like imploded in my head of just
because you didn't hear the countdown is
that what it never came in and then i
started to tell on the guy because i
wanted him to know that wasn't like a
weirdo and i was like oh sorry he the
guy told me he was going to count he
goes three two one you know what hold on
so the camera's out so i turn back and i
can't even
i i'm like outside my body going that
doesn't sound like bill maher that
doesn't sound like i couldn't even do my
impression like i couldn't access
that skill i was so terrified and and
just and i left nothing came out you
didn't do one i did everything sounded
like me there was no impression i just
seemed like i was like this is bill
maher hi how are you this is um this is
jeff goldblum how are you doing this is
and i left so i go backstage and i just
was sweating like that was terrible and
then the producer gathers everyone in
the room and goes hey guys when you go
out there say hi to lorne
so now everyone out there is going hi
everyone's just friendly and i was just
that's weird so you were the example
they used you as the example of what not
to yes they they had
when so this was years ago 2010 i think
right which is 12 13 years ago so
was it that yeah it's wrong
but you've never tried again
no
no
um but i'll tell you this
looking back i'm not like
that regretful because clearly i was so
scared that being on that live show you
got to be able to handle that now i feel
like i can because i do a live show
every week on youtube and i i i can
handle but at that moment it's very easy
to get lost on that show i've known
really talented people on there who get
fired after a year because if you don't
really but i think you're more talented
than anybody i know on that show right
now
thank you yeah and i also think that at
this point in your life you know
remember when um
you know marty short and billy crystal
and all those they were kind of not
young kids came back and started doing
it and kind of reinvigorated
the show
this would be your time
somebody
should even your agent should just make
them aware of what you're doing on
youtube
yeah
i mean there's 20 cast members now i
don't know how i know that's crazy even
it used to be like six or seven i
wouldn't worry about that if you got on
that show you will shine
because there was another kyle i'm
falling in love with losers
you can't deny the connection you cannot
deny talent is what i'm saying no he's
one of the most talented people i've
ever seen
[Music]
you